[MUSIC]
I burst through the door and
run up the stairs.
In my hands I'm clutching on to a brand
new box of general purpose Legos.
I set them down on the floor.
My brother scurries in behind me and
plops down next to me, we open the box.
Whoa!
Look at all the pieces.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Our imaginations are racing.
We dump out the box.
Pieces are all over the floor.
We're thinking, what are we going to make?
And we start to build and we build and
we deconstruct and we build some more.
Until by the end of it, the whole floor,
spreading across the whole
floor is a giant Lego city.
We are excited, we're looking at it with
awe, with a little bit of bewilderment.
This is fun.
So, I'm sure that at some
point in your childhood
you've had similar feelings of awe or
bewilderment, excitement.
Excitement about discovery, creating
something, or just learning something new.
Whether you built a fort or
sang a new song or something of the sort.
Take yourself back to that moment and
reimagine those feelings.
Now fast forward.
You're an adult.
The specter of responsibility
washes over you like a tide.
So you still have some curiosity,
but largely tracked paths and
societal structures
are getting in your way.
You don't really feel that youthful
sense of awe or exuberance anymore.
And this is tragic.
It's tragic for you, and
it's tragic for a society.
You see, our ability to innovate and
create and
change the world as a society is heavily
dependent on our creative ability,
our imagination, our desire to build.
If you look at the historical record, we
can find many examples of societies that
had fallen by the wayside when
they've lost their ability to create,
to innovate, to imagine.
Let's take an example.
Take yourself back to
the sixth century BC.
>> [LAUGH]
>> This is the Persian Empire.
You're in the capital city of Persepolis.
You're looking around in amazement
at the wonderful monuments and
sculptures, statues,
great architecture everywhere.
You also know that you're protected by
the most innovative military in history,
which is an accumulation of
people from many far off lands.
And the government is innovative too,
they've created the say trap system,
which is brand new and in full force.
But ultimately, stagnation sets in.
And within 200 years,
the Persian Empire has succumbed to
the forces of other
cultures who have become
stronger based on their own ability
to create, innovate, imagine.
In this case,
we know that culture to be the Greeks.
So we can sort of think
of this as on a graph.
If we plot the importance and
influence of a society on the y axis and
time on the x axis,
we sora get a bell curve sort of shape.
Rise and fall of civilizations,
if you will.
And if we plot innovations that
the societies are responsible for
in these little red dots, most of them
are to the left side of the peak,
and after the peak, not so
much innovation anymore.
Coincidence?
I don't think so.
Take the immediate successor to Persia,
the Greeks.
Very similar.
We're still familiar with a lot of their
contributions to culture, even our
culture today, but they still could
not retain their ability to innovate.
And it keeps going.
The Romans, The Byzantines,
all the way up until,
take a look all the way
on the right over there.
Looks pretty familiar, doesn't it?
We don't want this to happen to us.
Do not let this happen to us.
So we just looked at this arc
of society and civilization.
And remarkably it mirrors
the arc of our own lives.
We talked about our experience
in childhood and adulthood.
Take a moment now to try and
picture your own retirement.
You've probably succeeded in a lot of the
things you wanted to accomplish in life,
feeling pretty good about yourself.
Maybe you've got a house off in
the woods or on the beach somewhere.
But the reality of it is,
is that depression
actually increases by 40%
in when Americans retire.
This is largely due the fact that our job
is heavily tied to our creative purpose.
Additionally, suicide rates double for
Americans of retirement age, 65 to 85.
This all sounds a bit morbid but
at a large and
small scale,
the failure to create is fatal.
Now, I want to tease out this
connection between society and
the individual a little bit more.
Obviously individuals drive society.
And in a lot of cases these
individuals are people
who are committed and motivated and
working towards a goal.
But we tend to remember a lot
of people who simply achieve and
create because that's
what they like to do.
It's something that really speaks to them.
People like this might
include Benjamin Franklin,
Archimedes, Leonardo Da Vinci,
these guys are luminaries.
But it can't just be up to a small number
of people to drive society forward,
or to innovate, create,
it's up to all of us.
Let's take a local example.
So back when I was working
with my robotics lab,
one of the guys in the lab would come
in with this tub of Legos every day.
This is a 27 years old guy,
carrying his Legos.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And he'd build things with on his desk.
What are you doing?
But those ended up being prototypes for
some of the best robots that he built.
And he was unequivocally the best
design engineer in our lab.
He never lost his inner kid, he never lost
his ability to create and to innovate.
For me, my own experience with
building is really important to me.
My parents used to tell me when I
was growing up, do what you enjoy.
And for me, it was building Lego towns,
like the one I was talking about.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I wanted to just keep doing that.
But you get older, and
there’s no reason that this should stop.
No reason innovating and creating and
just having that sense of awe should stop.
In high school,
I was part of my first robotics team and
we built this robot here.
And I've since become an actual robotics
engineer, and this robot is one that
we made for the DARPA Robotics Challenge,
for disaster recovery scenarios.
This robot is meant to save lives.
So this is all very,
this is inspiring to me,
it's something that means
a great deal to me.
And I found there's almost sort of
current of inspiration and
fulfillment that skirting beneath
the surface of our lives.
And we just need to dig
a little bit to tap into it.
Now for me I get that through building and
creating, but
we all should seek to feel it.
Immerse yourself in creation and
discovery.
The best way to avoid personal stagnation,
by extension societal stagnation is to,
and to reach a higher state of fulfilment.
Is to dig into your passions and create.
Avoid the external,
the traps of external validation,
be it status, money, power and
think about what you love.
When you go to sleep tonight and
put your head on the pillow, think
about what you did today that was new.
What did, how did that make you feel?
What will you create tomorrow?
What will be new?
Pitch, what will be new?
JD, what are you going to create?
And do it, tap into your inner current.
You depend on it and
society depends on it.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]